welcome back to las vegas now some
heroes could really use a sidekick and
now is your chance to be one of those
heroes for the superhero 5k
i spoke to candlelighters the childhood
cancer foundation and a family involved
to learn more kimberly of candlelighters
and the lauren family welcome to las
vegas now
thanks so much for having us of course
of course i'm so excited to talk to you
guys about the superhero 5k so kimberly
why don't you start us out with just
telling us
why you guys are doing this again and
how important it is for our community
uh so candlelighter's childhood cancer
foundation of nevada we've been in
uh southern nevada for over 40 years and
our mission is to support
families and children who are going
through a childhood cancer battle
uh september is childhood cancer
awareness month and part of the way in
which we honor
our our warriors uh our brave little
kids and our amazing families
is through our superhero 5k uh which
kicks off on september 19th uh this is a
really great event that our families
participate in you're gonna hear
from you know one of our super
ambassadors
but it's a way for the community to come
out to support to raise money to make
sure that these families have
what they need as they go through a
really difficult
journey absolutely and let's jump to the
lauren family
how does this make you guys feel when
you know that this is happening in our
community for your little one
um it makes us feel very good um you
know obviously
when logan was diagnosed uh with brain
cancer about two years ago
uh you know we we didn't know who to
turn to
right like there's not a book that you
could open um that tells you
this is how you deal with a childhood
cancer
for your for your child right so you
know the first thing that we did
when we got home from the hospital was
contact
candlelighters and you know they they
really have been so supportive from day
one
for our journey so what can people
expect uh during the 5k and now that
it's virtual
what's changing so this is our 31st
uh superhero 5k it'll be the first time
we're doing it virtual
uh so you know it's a week-long event
this year so it goes from september 19th
through september 25th
we're going to have a kickoff on the
19th uh on facebook live so folks can
get excited and energized
um and then throughout the week uh you
know we'll be uh
asking teens and runners to post on
social media and keep the excitement
going
uh you know i remember having a
conversation they're like well what's a
what's a virtual 5k
so it's like well look you can run
anywhere at any time but you know if
you're like i don't really know where to
run or i'm new to it we also have
inspiration routes
and we'll have run leaders at different
locations to help people
you know uh stay safe social distance
but also feel like they're part of
something
obviously you can run anywhere like you
said but who can participate in how do
they get into it
so everyone can participate we even have
a registration for
uh dogs so you know go to our website
candlelightersnv.org
excited for that to kick off the candle
lighter superhero 5k
is from september 19th through the 25th
so for more information just call
702-737-1919 or just visit
candlelightersnv.com we also want to
thank blue apple electric
for sponsoring this segment lindsay